the pandemic has devastated the global
travel and tourism industry
no sector has suffered more and no
region has fared worse
than europe where revenues were down
almost 50 percent in 2020
this year many cities are eagerly trying
to win back visitors
yet they face stiff competition from the
great outdoors
and ongoing international restrictions
on travel
so will tourism ever recover
the arrival of summer to the northern
hemisphere brought great hope to tourist
destinations finally
a chance to make some money after a lost
season in 2020
but the coronavirus pandemic still hangs
over the sector
making a return to normal still elusive
we report from paris
paris loves its tourists that's the
message these young multilingual
ambassadors
are trying to spread
tourists shouldn't hesitate and just
come to paris we'll help them find their
bearings here at the santro pompidou
and all the other sites paris is such a
pleasant city and there are more and
more of us to help visitors
doing this makes me happy
up to 500 of them will be deployed this
year in an effort to kick-start tourism
again
after visiting numbers plummeted by
two-thirds last year
but the tourists who normally represent
a large share of the city's visitors
people from asia and the us might be a
bit longer incoming
we would like everybody to come back to
paris but we are obviously aware that
french and european tourists are likely
to be the first ones back
as it's still easier for them to travel
many hotels are trying to lure in the
locals with special deals
with some luxury establishments offering
discounts of up to 70 percent
but no offer will convince those already
desperate to get out of the city
this french couple have chosen to go to
higher ground
50 kilometers north of the french
capital
with this pandemic people have
understood that they needed to
disconnect from reality
such special offers aren't necessarily
so important for me
we need to breathe and take a step back
from work
especially as we've all been working
from home for quite a while now
they are not the only ones who feel the
urge to get out of the city bubble
reservations at these cabins have
skyrocketed
it's like people have flipped since the
beginning of the covet 19 crisis and
realized that they needed nature to
reconnect to who they are
we can't keep up with demand and are now
planning to construct an additional five
cabins
by the end of next year and yet
some might argue this is exactly the
right time
to visit paris or other cities here at
the louvre the world's biggest museum
foreigners make up three quarters of
visitors
but due to covert 19 restrictions many
of these
visitors from abroad are not showing up
that's why you can now even get tickets
at short notice
and visit world famous works of art
almost
by yourself what's true for the louvre
is true for other sites in the french
capital
you no longer have to queue for hours
and that might be
the most appealing tourist attraction of
all
we can now speak to freyja higgins de
biol who is a senior lecturer in tourism
at the university of
south australia thanks for joining us on
the kobit 19 special
it's hard to overstate the size of the
impact of the pandemic on tourism isn't
it
it really is these are extraordinary
times and for people who have been
through lockdown and repeated lockdowns
it's been so difficult and then trying
to get that balance right between
dealing with public health extraordinary
public health situation
and keeping the economy going or trying
to get tourism revived
it's really extraordinarily difficult
yeah so what are the main obstacles in
the way of tourism getting back to
normal
well we've never had a shutdown like
this for a global tourism system
so the difficulties have to do with
managing public health and we're finding
some very good
uh approaches particularly in europe
with things like
the digital covert certificate
which is going to enable european wide
travel
trying to get mass vaccinations out
and then measures with dealing with
possibilities of difficulty so using
contact tracing and so on
but the system has actually been run
down so for instance our aviation system
now
is in disarray because planes have been
put in
storage basically because our
aviation circuits are all shut down the
cruise industry has been
absolutely uh crippled by the these
events and is just now
um trying to wind back up uh so it's
extraordinarily difficult uh to
ramp up things again yeah i mean one of
the the big obstacles
as you mentioned is the potential
spreading of coronavirus and variants
of it and it has countries in this sort
of limbo of loosening and tightening
restrictions we've seen a lot of that in
europe around
the delta variant at the moment is there
a danger of people losing
all confidence in any holiday that they
book
well people who are um more worried and
careful are going to find it very
difficult and it will
probably be a couple of years before we
see
confidence and travel occurring again
there will be those who are
adventuresome and won't worry about
these difficulties and will be flexible
but you know following stereotypes that
tends to be the young
and in some countries we're not seeing
the vaccine rolled out quickly to the
young it's the elderly
and the people with health problems who
are getting the
vaccinations first so there's also that
aspect
to getting things rolling again i know
that a lot of young people are
really not used to this lack of freedom
that they're experiencing and they're
really
chomping at the bit to get out and
experience travel
so yes it's um amazing how
we're having to be patient we're having
to
wait and see how things unfold and i've
just learned in the news today that
some israelis who were vaccinated have
caught coveted
so we don't know how the various
vaccinations are going to provide
immunity
for how long all of those things
so there's a lot of moving parts to the
some
difficulty that we're in and the
use of travel bubbles or travel circuits
is one way that we're getting
uh tourism travel accommodations and all
of that
going again so europe will definitely be
one of the um
cases of seeing how things go and how
how we can get things
um successful again yeah you mentioned
about
how some people are just desperate to
get out there and travel again
is there a flip side to that and that
there are maybe now people who have
taken a liking to traveling within the
countries in which they already live
and that international tourism may not
get back to the position that it was
before
well it would seem that we're in a
era of really profound change and i
don't think the travel we knew before
will come back the way it was before we
took uh
cheap travel for granted and we thought
that we could go anywhere we wanted you
know just on
whims and for very inexpensive very easy
sort of holidays
and it's likely that travel will be more
expensive
for the next few years it's probably not
going to be as convenient because there
won't be so many routes to travel
or so many uh ease of scheduling um to
happen
and we have to be ready for instance for
things like
uh quarantine measures to be put in
place uh for perhaps another year or so
so those difficulties are likely to
remain we will see i think
the term i would use is a localization
of travel a narrowing of travel circuits
and even people wanting to know their
home countries you know sometimes we
take
our home country for granted and we want
to travel to other places
uh for the difference for the exoticism
and so on
so i think that we will find this more
narrow circuits
all right freya higgins debiol from
university of
south australia thanks for joining us on
the kobe 19 special
thank you so much
and now it's the part of the program
where we put one of your questions to
our science correspondent derek williams
do i have to have been given vaccines
approved in europe
to come to europe guidelines for
traveling
to and within the european union this
summer are
a work in progress and they're likely to
remain
pretty chaotic for a while um that's
because
member state governments actually make
their own rules
so so they vary from country to country
in other words
and what the french authorities or the
german authorities demand
that could differ in key ways from what
for instance
the spanish authorities demand or the
greek authorities demand
the eu as a whole is still trying to get
its ducks in a row when it comes
to travel and and the launch of a new
joint digital certificate for people who
have been vaccinated
or recently tested or who have recovered
from government 19
it should help but for the moment that
certificate
is still largely really aimed at
streamlining
cross-border travel for people within
europe and and a lot less so for
travelers
from third countries however according
to an official fact sheet on the digital
vaccine
passport member states only have to
allow free movement
for those who have been fully vaccinated
with one
of the four vaccines currently
authorized by the european medicines
agency the ema
although it does add that member states
may
also decide to extend the privilege to
travelers
who've received other vaccines but a lot
of eu countries
won't do that at least at first so
if you want to travel to europe from
outside the block
but you haven't been fully vaccinated
with either
pfizer biontech or astrazeneca or
moderna
or johnson johnson vaccines you
definitely need to check to see what the
restrictions are
in the countries that you want to visit
because
in many cases even full vaccination
might not be recognized if it wasn't
with a vaccine
approved by the ema
and that's all from this covid19 special
until next time goodbye and
take care
you